merci beaucoup d'être invité politique
ce matin vous êtes ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour et
bonjour on va évidemment parler de la
proposition de loi du Sénat sur le
recours au cabinet de conseils ce sera
ce soir vous nous direz ce que vous en
pensez mais d'abord l'actualité ça reste
cette crise des carburants 28% des
stations services connaissent des
difficultés d'approvisionnement ce matin
Emmanuel Macron s'est emparé du dossier
hier réunion à l'Elysée aujourd'hui il y
a une journée de mobilisation dans
plusieurs secteurs au-delà de la crise
des carburants est-ce que vous redoutez
une contagion de ce mouvement dans les
raffineries et une explosion sociale
c'est pas mon rôle moi j'ai pas à faire
des pronostics j'ai pas redouté à
espérer quand on est au gouvernement on
a agir en l'occurrence favoriser le
dialogue social quand il a pas eu lieu
et puis faire respecter ensuite les
accords principalement et singulièrement
quand ce sont des accords majoritaires
dans les entreprises c'est ça que le
gouvernement fait en l'occurrence
il y a eu des accords majoritaires et
puis il y a un syndicat minoritaire qui
continue de bloquer c'est ça qui n'est
pas compréhensible c'est ça qui n'est
pas acceptable je crois que nos
concitoyens attendent du gouvernement
qu'ils prennent ses responsabilités et
c'est ce que nous faisons vous avez
mentionner vous-même le fait qu'il y ait
des réquisitions elle continueront pour
libérer les dépôts
faire en sorte autant que nécessaire
évidemment et faire en sorte une fois
que c'est des pauses sont libérés que
des noria de camions puissent
approvisionner les stations d'essence
est-ce que c'est le cas partout est-ce
que la station est revenue à la normale
partout ça n'est pas encore le cas et
donc je veux aussi avoir un mot ce matin
pour tous ceux qui galèrent on voit bien
au quotidien les images on le vit dans
chacune de nos circonscriptions des
villes des difficultés des Français qui
veulent aller bosser et qui sont au fond
empêché par une infime minorité dans le
pays qui décide de bloquer donc moi je
vais être très clair je respecte
évidemment le droit de grève droit de
manifester mais je considère que le
blocage du pays ça c'est inacceptable et
en l'occurrence le gouvernement prend
ses responsabilités pour faire avancer
les choses faire redémarrer remettre la
situation à la normale parce que nous
nous pensons à ces ceux qui travaillent
on vous dites que votre rôle là où vous
êtes c'est d'agir en tant que ministre
la transformation et de la fonction
publique il y a une partie des
fonctionnaires qui se qui se mobilisent
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
faire pour eux agir ça veut dire quoi
pour eux aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a
des négociations nouvelles
une revalorisation des salaires à
remettre sur la table façon très
concrète ce que nous avons fait moi dès
que j'ai été nommé ministre j'ai eu à
prendre une décision sur l'augmentation
du point d'indice et en l'occurrence on
a augmenté le point d'indice des
fonctionnaires comme on l'avait pas
augmenté depuis 37 ans 3,5 %
d'augmentation donc ça c'est suffisant
s'ajouter
l'orientation moyenne j'ai eu cet
échange avec mes organisations
syndicales et j'ai eu l'occasion de
montrer que trois demi pour cent
d'augmentation du point d'indice qui
venait s'ajouter à un ennemi pour cent
d'augmentation moyenne dans la fonction
publique sont les augmentations telles
que nous avons vécu cette année en 2022
ça correspondait à peu près au niveau
d'inflation constatée sur l'année 2022
dans notre pays un peu au-dessous 5,4%
c'est 6% qui le dit je veux pas avoir ce
débat de 0,5 points même si évidemment
sont des des dixièmes de points qui
permettent parfois de boucler aussi les
budgets nous avons
aujourd'hui vous ne reviendrez pas sur
votre décision de ne pas faire de
nouvelles augmentations de salaire à la
d'ici la fin de l'année elles ne sont
pas prévues on aura évidemment des
discussions pour l'année 2023 moi j'ai
été très clair sur le fait qu'on a un
grand chantier sur l'attractivité des
carrières dans la fonction publique
c'est très clair je mènerai avec les
organisations syndicales ce chantier là
mais nous avons pris la table on verra
quelle est la conjoncture à ce moment-là
c'est difficile d'anticiper les
négociations de 2023 sur les discussions
salariales mais en tout cas l'inflation
se maintient à un niveau élevé là vous
pourrez le rouvrir le chantier le fait
que nous avons pris des décisions je
crois qu'elles étaient importantes
attendues légitimes pour l'année 2022 et
je considère que ce faisant n'avons pas
réglé la question de l'attractivité dans
la fonction publique elle est vraiment
sur la table et deux fois moins de
candidats au concours dans les 10
dernières années c'est un fake et
extrêmement significatif l'attractivité
ça se joue sur la fiche de paie et je ne
aucun chantier je pense qu'il faut
regarder les choses en face
l'attractivité c'est aussi pour les
fonctionnaires tout ce qui se passe en
termes d'organisation du travail de
formation de santé au travail d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et de
sens je crois que le défi qui est devant
nous c'est aussi de redonner du sens au
travail au quotidien des agents de la
fonction publique et c'est à ça que je
m'appelle aujourd'hui avec des
organisations syndicales avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes parce que ce
sentier de l'attractivité c'est la mère
de toutes les batailles et si nous
voulons apporter des services publics de
qualité à nos concitoyens alors il faut
s'intéresser à nos agents publics moi
depuis le premier jour je considère chez
le ministre des agents de la Fonction
chantier que vous déployez dès
maintenant ou là tout ça ce sont des
choses que vous allez discuter de
courant 2023 il y a des sentiers que
nous avons ouvert dès maintenant sur les
sujets qui concernent par exemple
l'égalité salariale on va ouvrir des
chantiers sur le logement des
fonctionnaires et des questions qui sont
très importantes en matière de
prévention en matière de santé sur les
lieux de travail donc ça vous allez
revenir sur la question des salaires à
vous rêver
c'est possible la question des salaires
d'un commun accord avec les
organisations syndicales nous avons
décidé de l'ouvrir en janvier 2023 après
les élections professionnelles c'était
la demande des organisations syndicales
pouvoir avoir ce moment de démocratie
sociale je m'engage pour que ce soit un
moment qui soit aussi réussi et puis
ensuite au premier semestre 2023 qu'on
puisse mettre à place cette question des
salaires et des carrières dans
l'administration dans la fonction
publique c'est ce que nous ferons et je
tiendrai évidemment mes engagements on
va parler des cabinets de conseils
puisque le Sénat examine ce soir la
proposition de loi vision à mieux
encadrer le recours à ses cabinets de
conseils c'est un texte qui est issu des
travaux de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat qui avait parlé je cite de
phénomènes tentaculaires et opaque le
texte du Sénat visa durcir le cadre du
recours à ses prestations est-ce que le
Gouvernement soutiendra ce texte ben moi
je l'ai dit j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire à votre antenne j'aborde ces débats
de façon extrêmement constructive j'ai
envie je crois comme les sénatrices et
les sénateurs qui ont travaillé dans
cette commission d'enquête de renforcer
l’état et renforcer l’état c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas le droit de recourir à des
prestations de conseils je pense que ça
serait une mauvaise position et une vue
un peu populiste que de dire ça c'est
parfois nécessaire mais renforcer l'état
oui c'est renforcer le cadre de contrôle
de recours à ces organismes assez
cabinets de conseils je n'arrive pas
dans les débats ce soir en ayant rien
fait en l'occurrence on a renforcé
l'accord-cadre qui permet au
gouvernement d'encadrer justement à ça
nous l'ont fait dès le mois de juillet
on a pris des engagements pour publier
l'ensemble des commandes de l'État nous
allons les mettre dans un document
budgétaire dont je peux vous dire que je
déposerai un amendement dans le projet
de finance pour que ça soit un document
pérenne qui chaque année soit une annexe
du débat budgétaire ça donnera toute la
transparence sur les commandes qui sont
faites on a pris des engagés oui en fait
ce que nous allons faire dans ce
document budgétaire c'est faire la
synthèse de toutes les commandes qui ont
été passées par les cabinets
ministériels tous les montants le dire
par type de cabinet par type de
prestation et par type de ministère ça
permettra de voir de façon extrêmement
fine quels sont les évolutions et de
faire toute la transparence donc cet
engagement là non seulement on le tient
mais je veux le pérenniser dans le temps
faire en sorte que amener après année à
chaque fois qu'il y aura des débats
budgétaires on puisse avoir cette annexe
budgétaire s'appelle un jaune budgétaire
qui fait la synthèse de toutes ces
informations là on avance j'ai pas
attendu pour pouvoir avancer cet
inventaire là ce jaune budgétaire comme
vous dites vous commencez vous commencez
à le faire à quelle année
dès cette année on publie un document
budgétaire qui fait la synthèse sur les
montants par mes mystères oui pour cette
année je l'aurais pas sur le quinquennat
de façon dernière année comparé aux
années précédentes donc vous le faites
aussi sur les cinq dernières années on
le fait par rapport à l'année 2021 en
l'occurrence qui a été une année où il y
a eu beaucoup de recours à des
prestations de conseils pour des raisons
qu'on peut expliquer puisque c'était
crise sanitaire qui a eu besoin d'un
apport permettra éventuellement
d'identifier un certain nombre de d'abus
ou des rives quels sont les ministères
qui ont plus dépensés de répondre à
votre question d'abord parce que c'est
une bonne question moi je souhaite
pouvoir renforcer le cadre de contrôle
faire la transparence prendre aussi des
mesures de déontologie pour éviter
absolument tout conflit d'intérêt
extrêmement sérieux
je pense que si on laisse ce sujet à
ceux qui en réalité sont intéressés que
par les polémiques qui ont envie
d'utiliser ce type de sujet là pour
taper sur le gouvernement au fond
d'affaiblir l'état je pense qu'on fait
une erreur sont pas les sénateurs je
veux dire extrêmement clairement je
pense qu'ils ont travaillé sincèrement
pour faire avancer les choses en
l'occurrence il suffit d'ouvrir les
réseaux sociaux pour en trouver un
paquet de gens comme ça des populistes
de tout bord au-delà des polémiques avec
un peu de recul est-ce que vous
reconnaissez qu'il y a eu des dérapages
vous en avez perçu sincèrement je sais
pas un terme que j'utiliserai parce que
en réalité quand on parle de dérapage on
donne le sentiment qui a eu une volonté
au fond préparait à l'avance de pouvoir
par copinage donner telle ou tel
contrats par manque de cadre que ce qui
est en train de se passer de créer un
cadre ça je le conteste absolument et à
rien de tout ça et rien eu de tout ce
que les polémistes en tout genre ont
parfois pu dénoncer sur tel ou tel
entreprise de conseil je conteste
extrêmement fermement est-ce que nous
avions besoin d'avoir un regard plus
précis plus exigeant sur l'utilisation
de tel ou tel cabine des prestations des
commandes de la façon dont on négocier
les prix je crois que la réponse c'est
oui donc vous voyez j'essaie de vous
répondre de façon équilibrée je crois
que on a tous intérêt je dis tous ceux
qui ont envie vraiment de renforcer
l’état à nous permettre d'améliorer le
cadre de contrôle c'est ce qu'on fait
par transparence par meilleur
encadrement tout ça nous l'avons mis
dans l'accord cadre et puis aussi parce
qu'il y a un vrai sujet derrière que je
vais aller pas du tout d'un revers de
main c'est comment est-ce qu'on réarme
au fond l'état comment est-ce qu'on
réinternalise un certain nombre de
compétences ça c'est le bon débat qu'il
faut qu'on puisse avoir et en
l'occurrence moi je n'ai pas attendu non
plus la proposition de loi pour pouvoir
avancer des cet exercice là dès 2023
donc dans le budget qui est en
discussion en ce moment-là national et
bientôt au Sénat nous avons pris la
décision de réinternaliser des postes de
consultants pour pouvoir plus faire en
interne avoir moins de besoins de
recours vous voyez on avance on renforce
le cadre on progresse mais moi je compte
sur tous et toutes pour le faire de
façon effective et de façon
proportionnelle c'est exactement dans
cette état d'esprit là que j'aborde les
débats de ce soir avec des sénatrices
avec des sénates vous avez sans doute lu
d'ailleurs la tribune de d'Elian assassy
et d'Arnaud basin qui était rapporteur
et président de cette commission
d'enquête c'était hier dans le journal
Le Monde le recours au consultant privé
devenu un réflexe pour l'exécutif au
détriment de sa souveraineté de sa
propre administration est-ce que ce
réflexe il est temps il vise juste là
sincèrement j'essaie de vous répondre
avec le plus la plus grande franchise
possible oui je pense que on a un effort
à faire de réinternalisation de
compétences nous sommes en train de le
faire et donc nous nous dotons des
moyens pour pouvoir avancer pour pouvoir
aussi ministère par ministère à chaque
fois se dire est-ce que cette mission là
est-ce que ce rapport-là on pourrait le
faire par exemple en mobilisant un corps
d'inspection parce que de temps en temps
il peut y avoir des redondances donc ce
sujet je le regarde absolument en face
mais je ne voudrais à aucun moment donné
l'impression qu'il y a une sorte de
volonté de favoriser tel ou telle
cabinet de donner du business à telle ou
tel ami ça n'est pas le cas je veux être
extrêmement clair avec vous et donc je
ne laisserai pas la moindre petite
moindre petite espace à des vues
populistes qui ne sont intéressés que
par la polémique en l'occurrence mais je
pense qu'il faut renforcer le cas
évidemment est-ce que l'État a eu
recours au Conseil de McKinsey depuis la
publication du rapport de la commission
d'enquête et depuis que pèse sur
makingset destruction d'optimisation
fiscale est-ce que vous avez eu un
nouveau recours en 2022 il y a eu des
recours parce que McKinsey a notamment
accompagné l'État sur des sujets de mise
en place d'instruments pour suivre la
crise notamment sanitaire et donc ça
n'est pas
légitime moi je n'aime pas ce débat
je vous parlais de l'appel d'offres et
de l'accord-cadre que nous avons passé
très largement renforcée qui a intégré
la quasi-totalité des recommandations de
la mission d'enquête sénatoriale et donc
il y a un appel d'offres en cours moi je
l'ai interdit à aucune entreprise de
candidater au fond je n'aime pas ce
débat qui pointerait du doigt tel ou tel
qui je trait le propre on voit bien
parfois ce qui est derrière cette
polémique qui a donné un nom
d'entreprise d'essayer de faire le lien
avec le président de la République de
faire des liens qui sincèrement ne sont
absolument pas avérés je veux le dresser
avec la plus grande clarté donc moi je
m'intéresse pas à tel ou tel cabinet je
m'intéresse à notre capacité collective
à renforcer notre cadre de contrôle et à
renforcer l'état ça ça m'intéresse
l'enquête du Sénat elle s'est concentrée
sur l'état elle a fait l'impasse sur les
collectivités locales est-ce que là il y
a pas un besoin d'encadrer aussi le
recours au cabinet
mais là aussi sans jamais donner
l'impression qu'il y aurait l'état d'un
côté qui serait contre les collectivités
ou les collectivités qui sont contre
l'État je pense que si on est sincère
c'est mon cas je crois que c'est le cas
des sénateurs dans notre volonté
collective de nous doter de meilleurs
outils pour pouvoir renforcer notre
cadre alors je pense que ça peut
s'appliquer effectivement et à l'état et
on les collectivités
j'ai porté cette abonnement je vais être
très transparent d'autres sénateurs et
sénatrices de différents bords
politiques d'air de différents bancs ont
porté des amendements pour qu'on puisse
avoir cette vue large collectivité et
état il y aura certainement un débat
important intéressant sur la taille des
collectivités concernées pour qu'elles
puissent assumer entre guillemets
l'organisation qui va derrière le
renforcement de ce cadre de contrôle
mais je pense ça sera un bon débat à
voir
ça n'est pas un débat illégitime dès
lors qu'on considère que ce texte il est
au fond bon pour l'État et bon pour les
collectivités
une autre une question sur le sur le
texte les sénateurs demandent à
interdire ce qu'on appelle les
prestations probonaux c'est à dire
qu'ils sont réalisés gratuitement au nom
du Bien Public est-ce que vous vous êtes
vous êtes favorable c'est interdiction
et pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut les
interdire oui je suis favorable et vous
voyez j'ai
en l'occurrence portait un amendement
pour encadrer l'écriture de ce article
là mais globalement absolument favorable
on a mieux écrit une exception qui
concerne le domaine culturel de mécénat
culturelle mais ça ne va exactement dans
le sens de ce que portait les sénateurs
et puis de donner la possibilité en cas
de crise qui met en danger la santé ou
la vie de la population pandémie une
guerre un moment très particulier sont
les deux seuls exceptions que je propose
de faire figurer dans ce texte là mais
comment que vous souhaitez des
exceptions à la règle en cas de crise en
cas de crise qui met en danger la vie ou
la santé de la population française
j'espère que c'est pas chaque année que
nous vivrons ce type de crise et je
crois que ce soit il est partagé autour
de la table et au-delà de cet écran mais
au-delà je vais dans le même sens que
les sénateurs et les signataires que
derrière une prestation gratuite il y a
il y a une espèce de cheval de Troie ou
de encore une fois moi je pense qu'il
faut se donner tous les outils pour
éviter toute prise à ce qu'ils peuvent
être de l'influence des conflits
d'intérêt potentiels et donc
effectivement la position du
gouvernement elle va dans le même sens
que celle qui est portée par les
sénatrices par les sénateurs de pouvoir
se dire on donne aucune prise donc pas
de prestation gratuite pour essayer de
se prémunir ou prévenir un éventuel
conflit d'intérêt pour plus tard
renvoyer l'ascenseur et donner telle ou
telle mission je pense que ça fait
partie des choses qui sont légitimes et
saines qui sont portées dans ce texte
un plafond de dépenses lors de recours à
des au cabinet de conseils pour vous
c'est ce que nous avons décidé de faire
dans le cadre de cette accord cadre dont
je vous parle depuis tout à l'heure en
plafonnant le montant de dépenses de
chacune des commandes et puis en faisant
quelque chose aussi qui pouvait avoir
lieu avant c'est-à-dire limiter le
nombre de droit de suite c'est à dire
qu'on pouvait pour un cabinet
ministériel pour un ministère initié une
mission et puis avoir plusieurs droits
de suite qui permettaient éventuellement
de dépasser les plafonds bah ça c'est
fini on a limité le droit de suite à un
par mission qui rentre dans ce plafond
là de 2 millions d'euros par mission
c'est beaucoup le montant moyenne des
missions c'est plutôt 55000 euros vous
voyez pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur mais effectivement vous voyez
que là aussi on renforce le cadre vous
parlez déontologie pendant la crise
sanitaire et c'est aussi ce que le
rapport du Sénat a mis en lumière il a
vu une certaine confusion entre les
salariés du privé et les fonctionnaires
des ministères concernés comment là on
garantit que ça ne sera plus le cas et
que cette confusion s'est terminée il y
a une mesure qui est portée par la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale et qui
est inscrite dans la pépette que je
soutiens largement c'est d'interdire
l'écriture en marque blanche c'est à
dire on sait pas qui tient le crayon au
fond savoir quand un document est publié
par une administration il pouvait y
avoir une confusion de savoir est-ce que
c'est le cabinet du ministre est-ce que
c'est l'administration est-ce que c'est
un cabinet de conseil qu'il a écrit ça
c'est fini à chaque fois désormais qu'il
y aura une mission de conseil sera fait
avec le logo du cabinet de conseil qui
aura fait cette mission pour avoir la
totale clarté la totale transparence sur
au fond la parole portée je crois que
c'était très important vous voyez sur ce
point-là aussi nous nous retrouvons et
nous renforçons encore une fois le cadre
l'état vous avez d'ailleurs un objectif
vous de réduction de 15% de recours au
cabinet de conseil cette année est-ce
que cet objectif sera tenu oui je crois
on est exactement en bonne voie pour
faire cela c'est ce que permet
d'ailleurs de vérifier le document
budgétaire dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et donc l'objectif je pense que
sincèrement nous le tiendrons et pour
les années suivantes bien entendu
100% chaque année totalement incohérent
au fond si je vous disais qu'on
réinternalise des compétences et que je
souhaitais pas tenir cet objectif-là là
aussi la corcade que nous avons pris
nous l'avons pris pour les quatre
prochaines années 150 millions d'euros
pour l'ensemble des ministères pour les
quatre prochaines années et donc c'est
totalement cohérent avec la circulaire
qui avait pris le gouvernement qui avait
pris le premier ministre à l'époque Jean
Castex le 19 janvier 2022 pour indiquer
que le cap c'était une réduction de 15%
et donc les engagements que nous prenons
pour les quatre prochaines années il est
exactement cohérent avec cette réduction
de dépenses
sur un accord ce soir ou demain en tout
cas si on peut durer je souhaite
parvenir moi je dis clairement on a eu
l'occasion d'en discuter ce matin je
porte les points qui pour ma part je
pense permettront de rendre le texte
plus effectif parfois plus proportionné
aussi dans les finalités qui sont
recherchées mon objectif c'est de
convaincre de convaincre qu'on puisse
améliorer ce texte ensemble et je
soutiendrai très largement oui et après
qu'est-ce qui va devenir ce texte est-ce
que vous souhaitez que la majorité s'en
empare à l'Assemblée nationale
examiné évidemment à l'Assemblée
nationale on va voir quel est le texte
qui sort du Sénat après il y a
différentes possibilités soit il sera
reprise sur une niche parlementaire des
groupes qui portent ce texte au Sénat ça
renvoie pas très loin il y a beaucoup de
niche parlementaires qui sont
accessibles soit je les scouts pas qui
puisse être repris par la majorité aussi
en tout cas moi le gouvernement si
jamais les parlementaires ne sont pas
vous le reprendrez permettez nous de
faire d'abord l'examen du texte ce soir
de voir quel est le texte qui sort du
Sénat pour ensuite pouvoir prendre une
position savoir s'il sera examiné dans
niche parlementaire à l'Assemblée ou sur
le calendrier gouvernemental
objectivement je n'ai plus rien les deux
sont possibles
cette ex puisse cheminer je vous le
confirme
sur les retraites le ministre du Travail
a commencé le premier cycle de
négociation avec les syndicats est-ce
qu'il y aura des négociations
spécifiques sur le sur les concernant
les fonctionnaires qu'elle sera votre
rôle dans la matière vous êtes vous êtes
impliqués dans cette démarche oui en
l'occurrence effectivement il y a des
discussions qui ont lieu en parallèle de
la discussion sur l'intégralité du texte
et le dossier effectivement porté par
Olivier du sable mais sur la façon dont
on traduit cette réforme pour la
fonction publique d'évidence ce sera ça
va être tendu
c'est des discussions qui sont toujours
très utiles moi j'ai pas les qualifier
de simple ou de tendus dites utile
évidemment moi je souhaite que le texte
puisse s'appliquer aussi à la fonction
publique y compris je veux dire en toute
transparence s'il y a un allongement de
la durée de cotisation ou un recul de
l'âge de départ ça doit s'appliquer de
façon symétrique pour la fonction
publique mais pour nous aussi si je puis
dire agent la fonction publique il y a
beaucoup de choses à discuter sur les
questions de
sur les questions aussi de cumul emploi
retraite de la façon dont on soit
aménage la fin de carrière sont des
bonnes discussions et nous les menons je
pense dans un état d'esprit constructif
avec des organisations syndicales une
dernière question sur le budget oui très
vite le 49-3 c'est pour aujourd'hui ou
pour demain
c'est pas ma décision c'est pas à moi de
le dire la question dès lors oh non ce
ne sont pas être une question vous êtes
des vrais vraiment piège parce que dès
lors que les oppositions ont dit depuis
le début de ce texte je le rejette pas
la pierre mais quel que soit les
amendements qui seront inscrits et
portés nous voterons courts contre
pardon c'est un lapsus révélateur la
logique du 49-3 elle me semble s'imposer
après c'est une question de calendrier
d'ici mercredi soir si je dis pas de
bêtises mais là je vous fais un peu de
langue de bois j'en suis conscient pour
terminer cette entretien merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité on
suivra bien sûr la séance qui démarrera
ce soir au Sénat sur ce recours au
cabinet de conseils on en parlera demain
matin avec rapporteur du texte merci
Stéphane d'avoir été avec nous Stéphane
on regarde la Une de Ouest-France
transport école énergie la grève
va-t-elle mobiliser c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup bonne
journée merci bonne journée
[Musique]